opportunity it's out there through
creativity hard work and soaring above
the norm you can seize it you are an
entrepreneur whether you're an undergrad
a graduate student and alumnus or a
faculty member the swart Center for
Entrepreneurship at Carnegie Mellon
University is your opportunity your path
to success where you bring your ideas to
market courses for credit at Carnegie
Mellon are at the core of the ecosystem
supported by countless extracurricular
programs global resources and networks
that launch companies entrepreneurs jump
into the Swart Center ecosystem at
anytime to build a unique path and
collide with ideas creativity and
visionaries also striving for success
consider a student while attending
entrepreneurship bootcamp he learns
about the sort Center incubator project
Olympus giving him the opportunity to
earn a spark grant which provides the
capital needed to launch his startup he
then becomes a Swartz Fellow a cohort
program for entrepreneur training or a
faculty member who through the National
Science Foundation iCore program
discovers had a commercialize her
research which then gains recognition at
launch CMU the Swartz centers public
entrepreneur showcase of student alumni
faculty and staff at the same time her
PhD student earns additional funding by
winning the McGuiness venture
competition for CMU students and becomes
an innovation fellow an alum takes full
advantage of the Swartz Center connects
workshops and gets mentoring from the
entrepreneur in residence who suggests
joining the I coresight program during
this program the alum learns about the
open field entrepreneurs fund which
provides seed funding to recent alumni
for every entrepreneur every research
project every business idea our
centralized ecosystem creates unique
paths to learn network commercialize
invest and launch the next great startup
the sport Center is a great place
because with all the resources at
Carnegie Mellon it's all being put under
one roof and that's amazing the quality
programs at Carnegie Mellon is the
people it's the fact they interact with
each other it's the fact that there is
this more community spirit here that's
really important and really helpful in
starting businesses students and faculty
are really able to come together and
share their thoughts and opinions and
experiences regarding entrepreneurship
Trent seminars that were free and open
to anyone on campus was incredibly
helpful to me everybody has an
extracurricular activity that they enjoy
and that they're really passionate about
and they sort of combine their passion
with their major and that is exactly
what is necessary to be a successful
entrepreneur the Swartz Center for
Entrepreneurship
at Carnegie Mellon University